the numbers of tigers in the wild in
Southeast Asia have dropped by more than
70% and little more than a decade that's
the claim in a new report from the WWF
the organization says there are an
estimated 1,200 tigers in the Greater
Mekong region during the last year of
the tiger in 1998 today WWF estimates
there are only about 350 their wild
tigers have even been wiped out in
several reserves set up to protect them
the Greater Mekong region includes China
Cambodia Laos Myanmar Thailand and
Vietnam the reason for the drop WWF says
the tiger crisis has developed because
of deliberate and large-scale illegal
hunting of tigers for body parts mostly
for use in traditional medicine here
tiger parts are seen displayed for sale
on a street in Bangkok enforcement of
poaching has had limited success such as
these scenes from Vietnam where
illegally poached Tigers and carcasses
were confiscated by authorities the WWF
hopes to raise awareness and funds to
stop the poaching according to the
Chinese zodiac 2010 is the year of the
tiger and later this month ministers
from 13 tiger range countries will meet
in Thailand for a conference on tiger
conservation it's hope the government's
will agree on future needs in protecting
this big cat from extinction